[music]
Poland was abandoned by the Western allies
to be devoured by the German military machine and
actually lost its independence and
statehood, which was
restored to a huge extent
thanks to the Soviet Union
and it was thanks to the Soviet Union that, thanks to
Stalin’s position, it received more
significant lands in the west of the
lands of Germany,
this is precisely  so the
western territories of present-day Poland are
Stalin’s gift to the Poles,
our friends in Warsaw forgot about this,
we will remind
us strongly Polish
[music]
[music] [
music]
[music]
as for the Polish leaders,
they are probably counting on using the NATO
umbrella to form some kind of coalition and
directly intervene  into the conflict in Ukraine
in order to then tear off a fatter piece for themselves
and regain what they consider their
historical territories of today’s
western Ukraine, it is
well known that they also dream about the
Belarusian lands. As for the
policy of the Ukrainian regime, it is
his business that they want, as is usual with
traitors, to surrender something  sell something to
pay off the owners, I will repeat this in
the end, their business. We
will not interfere in this. As
for Belarus, it is part of the
union state and unleashing
aggression against Belarus will mean
aggression against the Russian Federation;
to this we will respond with all the
means at our disposal  the
whole world sees that the vaunted Western
supposedly invulnerable equipment is on fire,
and in terms of its tactical and technical characteristics,
it is often even inferior to some
Soviet-made weapons.
Yes, of course, Western weapons can be
additionally supplied and thrown into battle;
this, of course, causes us some
damage and prolongs the conflict
[music  ]